Hey, guys,
it's Lily Brooks O'Briant here.
And I am playing Ella McCaffrey
in the show Life by Ella.
My character
Ella went through cancer.
Now that treatment's over,
she just wants to live life
to the fullest.
Tackling fears and taking names.
This show is honestly so amazing.
The other actors and I
are super excited
to answer some questions
and have fun.
Let's do it.
I'm excited.
Hey, guys, what's up?
My name is Artyon Celestine,
and I play Kai.
Today we're playing
two truths and a lie,
and you guys have to guess
which one is a lie.
Number one,
I used to be a gymnast.
Number two, I have a bearded
dragon named Quincy.
And number three, I'm on
the varsity basketball team.
The lie is
that I'm on the varsity
basketball team.
I can't say I'm great at basketball,
but thanks for guessing
that's true if you did.
My name is Vanessa Carrasco.
I play Ximena
on this amazing show.
I've watched Jane
the Virgin over three times.
One of my cats names is Midnight,
and I've been in a movie
starring Christopher Walken.
The lie is that one of my cats
name is Midnight.
His name is actually Shadow.
Close enough.
Hi, my name is Aiden Wallace,
and I play Grady McCaffrey
on this show.
I am top 100 in Madden
NFL on Xbox.
I hate the outdoors.
I love the Rams, the NFL team.
The one that's a lie
is...
that I hate the outdoors.
And I said I'm top 100 in MADDEN
All right, I'm like 92nd or something
but I don't play it all the time.
I go outside a fair amount.
Hi, I'm Kevin.
Rahm and I play Carl the Dad.
I have a charity golf tournament
to raise money for St Jude's
Children's Research Hospital.
I played
this game with Eva Longoria.
I had
lunch with the president
of the United States.
I did not have lunch with the
president of the United States.
No.
Hi, I'm Mary Faber.
I play Joanne
McCaffrey on the show.
I've been in three Broadway
shows.
I have two kids.
I'm a descendant of royalty.
The one that's not true is
I am not descended from royalty.
(Excited screaming)
Would you believe that
I have been to Disney World
12 times.
I lived in New York City and
my favorite food is caviar.
Drum roll, please.
I actually hate caviar.
It was not good. It's
not good at all.
It was really salty. I didn't like it,
but I tried it.
And that's something
I've actually learned
from my character.
Ella is going to try everything
and she knows that
if you're scared
to do something,
you have to get over it
and just try it
because you only have one chance
to live your life
and you have to just
have fun and be yourself.
Cannonball!